all right
uh i'm tom preston hello and we
are two of the four founders of uh
chubby shorts
um first off happy friday to everyone
um
i don't see nearly enough shorts in the
audience but
yeah so today we are talking about a
very technical term of how to build a
brand
lovegasm
and without further ado we'll jump into
it
so first our story
basically background is uh we're four
buddies from stanford
uh who are all working random different
odd jobs i was in venture capital
preston was in the startup world uh one
of the other guys was in finance one of
the other guys was in retail at cap
and we all were just kind of getting
tired of the day-to-day
and of reporting to people and wanted to
be doing things for ourselves wanted to
start something and there was just
one fateful day where uh we decided on
of all things making tiny shorts for men
um
and and uh and made just a really small
crop
back in uh the fourth for the fourth of
july of 2011 for just our close buddies
um and we had maybe like 10 left over
we went to lake tahoe and everyone in
our group was wearing them and then
whatever we had left we were just
carrying in backpacks
went out and they we just sold out of
everything that we had on our backpacks
people were buying them off of our
physical bodies
um so it was really cool and and for us
was really good kind of
initial validation that hey at least you
know 20 people
like what we're up to um and
and so that's when we decided to make a
little bit more
um and just kept kind of having this
this routine of making you know 30
50 90 100 and selling them in person
selling them at tailgates selling them
going out in san francisco
and and at some point we were just
you know we decided uh it was time to
kind of invest
and and do a little bit more uh and so
in september of 2011 we officially
launched
chubbyshorts.com um
and uh and started selling online um
and and for about you know the better
part of that kind of fall winter
it wasn't very exciting it was pretty
mellow we were selling you know maybe
100 shorts a month or something like
that
um until our first spring
and that's when things started going
haywire um
we took this picture during the that
boring fall
yeah pointy island shorts so we just
might as well we are a very photogenic
bunch
the christmas card picture sent out to
our small number of customers but
hopefully it brightened all of their
christmases yeah um so we got through
our first holiday season
it was it was exciting um and and we had
one guy full time it was basically me
working out of cafes
um in january raynor one of the other
co-founders jumped on and in march
preston jumped on and that's when we
really started to pick up steam
and basically from march to july we were
100 sold out of inventory
so we started doing a lot of pre-sales
and selling products ahead of
when we actually had them in stock so
that we could finance the business we
didn't want to raise any money we just
wanted to be able to grow
based on the consumer demand and people
luckily were willing to wait
one two and a you know sometimes almost
three months to get the product
and and then from then on it was it was
a pretty solid growth pattern so
um now you can see we're still very
photogenic
um take great just way more creative
take the couch and put it outside yeah
exactly
and so now this is where we're at and um
and you know there's there's a lot of it
is fortune and a lot of it is
is premeditated and so what we're going
to try and do in the talk is is
is lay out what we think are the really
important pieces of building brand um
and and brand to us is the emotional
association a customer has with your
company and with your products
um and so our entire talk is about brand
and that concept of really forging that
association
um and and uh
so you know this is where we're at so um
facebook we have
860 000 fans in you know two and a half
years
uh and i think that makes us
first your second biggest in terms of
just a men's focus brand
on facebook and the other
community stats you can see here a ton
of social engagement our our customers a
very young guy
um and very willing to to be involved
and participate in the brand that we've
created which is
totally awesome and we've seen a ton of
success with social
and then revenue-wise we've had
a lot of good solid growth um
and uh hope to see that you know lion
continue ticking up into the right
um so one thing i would maybe add to
sorry to cut you off tommy is just the
applicability to
hopefully everyone here on brand
maybe not everyone here is selling
clothing online maybe no one else is but
but the notion of a brand being
important regardless of what you're
doing
being consumer facing we think really
matters i think you guys are also
probably realizing that it does matter
as well that perception that a consumer
has that a potential customer has
of what you're doing as being the best
and establishing that and finding ways
to establish that
really help so so hopefully this is just
generally applicable to everyone here
that brand does matter regardless of
what you're doing
yeah and so so here uh we're not going
to try and be too prescriptive
we're going to try and give what we
found to be successful
so that hopefully you guys can glean
bits that are applicable to your
specific business and your specific
brands
so basic outline for us that has been
the formula for
success and and building a really solid
uh
emotional connection with a custom base
is first you have to have a great
product
you can market the heck out of something
that's not very good
and ultimately that will shine through
um so
it all is rooted in great product and as
you can see
we uh we have done that um
second is relentlessly focus on content
content from day one was an enormous
part of our business
the first thing that i wrote when i was
sitting down to build the
the website was this concept called the
facts and it was basically laying out
in content form a lot of very very
branded and ridiculous details about the
company
and our manifesto which is uh basically
our call
uh to the uh to the previously cargo
laden
uh masses to toss them out and shorten
up their shorts
um but from from day one it was it was
very rooted in content not just product
third is community integration and this
one was something that kind of
uh happened to us as opposed to was was
too premeditated
as we started selling product and
putting out content we started getting
back content from our community
and it was just natural to us to recycle
that and
integrate it into our website into our
purchasing behavior
and all that good stuff four is customer
support
to to have a great brand and this is
something that that is now almost
assumed but
should not be trivialized is just
customer service customer support
and and being you're being always
uh always having your customers back
it's it's more than just customer
service
it is you are that guy that is there to
help them out in any situation and we'll
talk a little bit about that later
and then five and this kind of runs
through everything is authenticity
uh hugely hugely hugely important
um and one and the one specific facet
where so many brands get off track um
is authenticity um and we'll we'll talk
about kind of the way that we think
about that
so that's the rough outline and we'll
run through it
so first great product we discussed this
but but basically you have to ensure
that what you're doing is high quality
whether you're making shorts or you know
software or whatever
the product has to be on point and has
to be
something that people will be extremely
happy with
um yeah
that's the basic i mean all you guys are
building great things that's that's just
step one to be able to build a brand
around something
it's got to be something worth building
a brand around and this is just kind of
assumed
preston and i are the kind of marketing
dudes and luckily
we don't have to we have a great product
team that helps us out with this
second and where we get a lot more
involved is is on content
um so we are
just extremely rigorous about content we
think about our content organization in
the same way that we would think
you know comedy central would think
about their content organization or you
know
uh jimmy fallon would think about his
content organization we treat it as a
media outlet and we think that
everything that we put out has to be
on a caliber of entertainment as
all of those things
so here you can see basically
this is one of our social posts of the
past week
and this level of engagement we have
about 1400 likes
21 shares and a few comments
this level of engagement is very very
very high if you go look at any other
brand let alone men's brand getting your
community to get involved like this
uh is tough and and luckily we've been
fortunate enough
um to uh to be able to have this level
of engagement
um but this is an example of something
where a customer sends us a photo
and then we take the time to kind of
caption it in an interesting and unique
way
isn't salesy we don't ever try and sell
products on our social channels
we just want to give people something
interesting and entertaining in their
newsfeed
um and and it seems to work and seems to
pay off
one thing i would add is is it's maybe
applicable to obviously you're not going
to necessarily be posting pictures of
of someone working at their computer
using your software or something like
that but
but high level although that could be
pretty cool you might and maybe it works
i'm not gonna say don't do it
but the general notion of making your
customer
in some way a hero is potentially
something that can apply to to what
you're doing
and and be a very authentic we get to
authenticity in a second but
be a very authentic authentic
representation of
wow this is this is kind of the value in
some crazy way of
that i'm bringing to the world or or
that real people
are experiencing through what i'm doing
so making the customer the hero
the other the and this kind of brings
like one of the first big points about
content
is that content is shareable um into
in this day and age there are many ways
that people can share
best is people talking about it but
second best
is people commenting liking and sharing
uh in social media channels
these are all indicative of potential
conversations that people can have
that's kind of the way that we think
about it
and here you see you know 300 likes
is 300 opportunities for this piece of
content
to get dispersed into other people's
news feeds who have never heard about
chubbies
and then their first experience is not
only seeing the social validation from
their friend
but also seeing that on a great piece of
content that has been validated so
um step you know number one about
content is it's very shareable when you
do it right
um and and facebook is is kind of mecca
for us
getting these pieces of content
distributed throughout other people's
news feeds without paying for it
is huge um and so that's step one
um and here here you've got uh
we're just going to run through a few
homepage assets that we have so these
are kind of the first things that a
person would see
coming to the site and so you can see
just there's always an interplay of
the photograph and the copy that we
always have
never salesy we don't do discounts we
don't do promos
uh this is the extent of what we do um
and so we'll just run through them
relatively quickly it's done just
you know if you have your comments out a
bunch of fun being had obviously i think
that's one thing to say about that
uh protest the top button we do a lot
around
uh not business casual uh
workwear um and so uh this is kind of
getting to the notion of
of you know live the dream live the
weekend all the time
and and the top button is is one of our
enemies just as pants are
dehydration is no joke this is just a
public service announcement
um this is serious
that's good the other the other thing to
really recognize is that everything is
content
from your labels uh to internals
to packaging to your emails to your
order confirmation emails anything that
a customer sees
from your brand is an opportunity to
have a positive content experience
so here you can see a few examples we
ship out koozies with all of our orders
and they're not just a utility to keep
your hand warm while you're drinking a
cold beer
there there's always content on them
this tank top that you see
is one of the one of the hottest
commodities that we've got and we don't
sell it
it's all loyalty item and you know we
see this going on ebay for
50 to 60 bucks and then
you can see the top left our box it's
another content experience
first time customer opens that up they
get a hearty boom shakalaka when they
when they open up their
first box bottom right getting emails
from chubby's makes my day
that's awesome and then this bottom left
here is an order confirmation email
where we insert a lot of branded copy a
lot of content and just opportunities
for people to get
more involved talk about it with their
friends share it one thing i would add
is
is you may think about okay well content
content strategy that's
that's always sort of generally talked
about in in none of these examples is
there a mention of just
our blog or having a blog as that being
the manifestation of content it's um
i think it's just generally thinking
through every touch point that a person
has with what you're doing and thinking
of how you can make that
exceptional from start to finish and so
you have
a surprising number of opportunities
when you think about all those different
touch points
to wow the customer that is is seeking
out what you're doing
and so it's it's not necessarily just
hey get a blog
it's just think through every touch
point as an opportunity to
provide an entertaining brand building
experience yeah and the last thing i put
on here is
is that content doesn't have to be copy
video content can be a shareable
experience one of the examples is
we sent out about a thousand packages of
big league chew just randomly
to folks who ordered on like a random
tuesday
and that created a content experience
because they all
shared it on twitter talked about it
with their friends
and hopefully shared shared some
delightful bubble gum uh there amigos
um so once again stressing this but
content is your voice
content is the brand uh first is why
content is important
second people share it people talk about
it it gives people a different reason
to to promote your brand and especially
with guys guys aren't often talking
about that you know
new fashion item that they purchased
they'd much rather talk about a funny
video or funny piece of content
and third and and uh more subtly content
and something that we learned along the
way is content serves as a model for
user generated content
um so our content that we put out um
then is replicated by our customers
sending it back in
i don't think when we started this we
thought that we would start getting
thousands of guy selfies
every week which is awesome
yeah that's fantastic but we do and it's
guys wearing hawaiian shirts and
uh guys looking ridiculous and going out
and having fun
and we didn't realize at first that that
would be the response to what we were
doing we were just having fun and
marketing to our buddies but that's what
it turned into and it was
just totally awesome and one of the
things that i would take as
as subtle but impactful with your
content strategy
and in the next three minutes that we
have we'll zoom through the rest of the
presentation
okay three is uh community integration
um so
this is related to the third point of
why content but really work to integrate
your compu
your community and support your
community uh these are all user
generated photos
none of this was taken by us uh and
frankly just couldn't have been this guy
is like
40 feet in the air on a motorcycle not
any of us could do that
um and yeah so i guess we can keep on
running through so so this is our
instagram account um
most of what we do in social media is
taking uh our customers photos and
turning them into heroes with a caption
and promoting their photo and when
people see this they get so excited
tag their buddies tell everyone they
know about it
and this has been really really awesome
for us uh our customers
are our best photographers our best
content producers
um and and uh we really like to
highlight that
um and whatever it is i mean for for you
guys it's
i think it takes a while to establish
a consistency and expectation for what
you you choose to do if you do choose to
do something on social or if you do
choose to
find a variety of other channels you can
use to communicate with your
potential folks is over time people
started to understand that this is sort
of how it worked that there was this
notion of i'm going to submit my photo
in hopes that they'll actually turn me
into a hero and and make me look
the best way i can possibly look in
front of
my set of friends and then this broader
community as well and so people then
it became sort of this reinforcing cycle
but um
allow that to happen for for whatever
you choose it may not be this but but
allow that to happen so someone can
start to understand
and have that understanding and
expectation so that it can sort of start
to build but but that first part takes a
little while
um and so there are a lot of different
ways you can
integrate your community here we're also
providing hero images of our customers
as
model shots on our website and
we've seen statistically that having
user generated content
on these pages increases conversion rate
people get excited when they see it
it provides social validation and it
provides these guys with a reason to
tell their buddies about it so
a really big thing for us that we've
recently learned is just this
integration
uh should just be throughout your
business
yes these are our values you see and yes
our customers are awesome
second way that our community gets
involved is in basically
aiding in our manufacturing decisions so
this is a concept that we launched a few
weeks ago
called chubby's labs where we can just
put out ridiculous
over-the-top concepts without actually
manufacturing them and have our
community
pre-purchase them it only activates if a
certain number are purchased
and this has been really cool so we ran
this with a few state flag shorts
because previously we had done a lot of
state flag activations but only around
the states where we knew there were a
lot of customers or knew there would be
sufficient traction to justify the
manufacturing
here we got to take a shot and then give
people you know
six different state flag shorts and only
make the ones where we had
a lot of traction and a lot of
shareability and so this is another way
to really involve your community
that makes them feel special makes them
feel exclusive
number four is customer support customer
service uh
here are just brief tidbits uh this
slide used to be just
full and it just didn't look good so uh
we trimmed it down
uh but basically our customer service
reps
uh are you know that front line and the
voice
of our brand and so um you gotta have
great customer support
and and we don't outsource it we don't
think that's the right way to do it
uh because brand and voice are so
important um
we in-house all of the customer service
and
if you call into chubby's you'll be
greeted very warmly so i recommend you
guys check it out
but people really really respond to it
and once again it turns into a content
experience where people will share
and and tell their friends about it the
other thing i would add is is
often times tom and myself are also
taking phone calls from folks
and i would just say as your company
starts to grow don't allow yourself to
get removed from answering the phones
even if it's just a couple times a day
but it's just so valuable to continue to
have that interaction and
use it as an opportunity to ask
questions of how are you liking this
or just to thank them or or do whatever
but but still being
my personal phone number is on one of
our box inserts so i randomly get calls
from folks asking for
refills of their referral cards and it's
awesome to know that a guy just handed
out
five business cards that have a promo
code to
get a gift with their first chubby's
purchase but it's also awesome then that
they call in to get more of those cards
and it's a great opportunity to just be
able to
do the things that i just mentioned but
don't allow yourself to get detached
from that as you grow
so there's a lot of different ways to
support your customers one of the ways
we found
uh that's just a case study of not of
going above and beyond
is uh we saw just this random guy who is
a customer of ours
made a video of himself in kind of old
spice fashion
asking miss texas out on a date to his
you know formal
um here is his reaction and a
you know a videotape of him reacting to
miss texas
accepting his offer on the news um and
so we took it upon ourselves to
get him a bouquet of flowers book a limo
for him
to and from uh his his formal
uh and hooked him up with a few free
pairs of shorts
to make his experience that much better
and that's something we're just randomly
we saw it locked onto it coordinated it
and did it and it went above and beyond
for this guy and and made a huge huge
difference he told his friends about it
shared it on social media
really really cool and a way that you
can turn all of these into
really cool content experiences um
yeah and and another example of this uh
that we didn't have good photographic
stuff for is uh
there was a guy who emailed in saying
that his chubbies were stolen at the gym
and so obviously we replaced them but we
also did
is is we figured this guy could use some
help we booked him for uh self-defense
classes and so we got him into
uh we got into uh some karate classes
and uh it was really cool really funny
really shareable
number five is be authentic um that guy
is authentic right there
so this is you gotta live your brand uh
everything that you're doing
needs to feel good it needs to feel
right um and the way that this
this kind of manifests is us is just
picture your brand as a person that's
talking to people that's sharing things
uh would you want to hang out with that
person um
and in this case yeah
i mean it's pretty answer is clear um
but but this really pushes the notion of
don't sell don't
be in people's faces uh no one likes
when their friends are like
non-stop posting about them coming to
their events or whatever so
so just think of it in that way and
you'll be like oh wow yeah i guess
people probably wouldn't like to see
that uh and and for us we don't ever try
and sell
selling feels bad by all means we'll
give customers the opportunity to buy
and and the content inspiration to buy
but we're never trying to sell we're
never doing the you know hey comment
this to get uh all sorts of free stuff
um we we use the content to provide that
drive
as opposed to creating an artificial
experience
and so one of the most authentic ways
you can come across is in person
an example of this is we just bought a
gigantic rv
that's going to be touring the country
and going to tailgates throughout the
fall
where the whole rationale is to bring
people together and have a good time
we're going to we're
ideally you know long term going to be
kind of the espn college game day
but for having fun um
and so so what we're going to be doing
is we're going to deck this thing out
with
a bar dance floor dj booth all sorts of
stuff like that
so that um we are that that that just
mecca of fun
at all of these tailgates and and for us
the best way that we come across is in
person
the best experiences people can have and
the most authentic is just talking to us
we've seen we've seen this time and time
again is is when people come away from
an in-person experience with us
they're that much more stoked and it
gives people a real tangible
understanding of who we are and what we
do
um so don't downplay this get out and
hang with your customers
meet them tell them about what you're
doing people are always interested in
your stories
because you know they know your brand
and they already love your brand they
just
they want to learn more about it and no
better way to bring the brand you're
building whatever it is and whatever it
stands for to life
so closing um you know basically a
repetition but
but focus on great product um that's the
baseline
second crazy focus on content
um constant editing don't let things
through that don't feel good
uh three integrate your community they
serve
as even more content and giving them
that validation is huge
uh four gotta have great customer
support um
and that can also turn into content
experiences
and five is be authentic um
and so with that i hope we have time for
questions i'm not sure
i think we went like 30 minutes over
we do have time for questions thank you
thank you everyone thank you thank you
for listening
appreciate it
come on down if you have questions for
the chubbies guys we can take probably
two or three chubby chubby guys
chubby guys chubby fellas chubby fellows
hi there i was wondering um in a sea of
technology startups
once you got started and it became
difficult how did you stick with this
idea especially
you know in fashion among a bunch of
guys
so first off we don't consider ourselves
a fashion company we are a beer brand
that happens to sell shorts
um uh second is
that this is the most fun that we could
ever imagine having um
i was i was actually all set to go to
business school when i when we started
this
and once this started picking up there's
just no other thought in my mind
um and uh you know honestly i'm working
with my best friends
um and the people that we've hired in
the company are the greatest people ever
and the other piece is that it's it's
different um people don't expect it
uh which is really cool and really fun
the the other two things i'd quickly add
one being able to see that initial part
that tom was talking about
we're just we have shorts in our
backpack and we're walking around san
francisco and people are just saying
i want the things that you have on do
you have any i will buy them right now
seeing that even though it was we did
that maybe 10 times in total
you saw wow there's something there's
some reaction that a person is having
that seems like this could touch more
people and have a similar impact on more
people so that
even if there are tough times you you
remember moments like that
the other thing is just we wear these
things every day
so as it relates to the product you're
making whatever if it's shorts or if
it's software whatever it is
using it every day and loving it every
day if you're just honestly doing that
that means something
great presentation um where did you guys
get your first pair of chubbies designed
and did where did you decide to
manufacture
and how did you find a manufacturer so
that's just legwork honestly uh when
you're when you're
getting into this world in the world of
manufacturing it's just a lot of legwork
so it started with a google search
uh and then was just
us going out and visiting manufacturers
google search
did not work at all but but it's talking
to people asking them who they work with
so you know u.s manufacturing is very
very dispersed
people don't unify it up you know
vertically so
there's a manufacturer who works with
all sorts of fabric suppliers who works
with all sorts of button suppliers
and so as you get down the funnel you
ask each and every one of them
with whom they're working and then you
start getting references you start doing
your exploration so when you get
referred to a fabric guy
from this manufacturer then you ask that
fabric guy what manufacturers do you
work with and then you go meet other
manufacturers
but it was a long process definitely
aided by the fact that we had a guy who
had worked at
the gap in levi's before but
totally totally not it is a competitive
advantage to be able to
put in that work because a lot of people
don't um and
uh so yeah i got it it's just a lot of
you know hitting the pavement but it's
well worth it
did you design the shorts yourself or
did you outsource that
uh we designed the look but we're not
pattern makers so so
patterns are basically the way that a
cutter will cut the fabric
and design the way that should be sewn
together we don't
do that but basically we had the cut and
the look that we wanted
and then we went through multiple revs
with a pattern maker
to finally get the exact feel and look
that we had in our mind so kind of both
i guess
because you're manufacturing in the us
did you commit to a smaller batch at
first and then
go larger yes uh but yeah yes definitely
um but how one of the innovations that i
think really helped out our business
was that was was the concept of
garment dying for us basically we made a
bunch of white shorts
and then dyed them different colors and
and that really helped us because we
could make a whole lot of white shorts
and then sell
10 different products where we're not
too heavily inventoried
but that was never a huge issue for us
because we were sold out since march
and have and up until the point where
we were big enough scale that just
didn't matter anymore um
we were just selling out so so it was it
was
in the early days a story of how can we
maximize
um variety based on a single kind of
manufacture
but now it's it's a lot different cool
thanks thank you
hello uh so i'm 48 i hate those kind of
stuff
things like you look like ridiculous
when you wear that so how can you
to each their own to each their own
we'll get yourself all right that's all
right
i'm french so i have to do something so
you have to be excited
so um how can you i was listening
carefully i had to make a call but
i was listening carefully so how can you
convince me
to that it's cool and what what great
product all right but what what's
what's what's the specific thing your
friends will convince you
your friends will start wearing it and
then they'll tell you all about i have
no choice
yeah really you think my friend's okay
you will start to become unfashionable
always good to end with a trolling
comment there so uh thanks very much i
hate what you do
all right thank you so much